[Müzik]
[Alkış]
Anladım sonu yok yalnızlığın
her gün çok
[Müzik]
her zaman böyle miydi
bilmiyorum
sanki
dokunulmazdı çocukken ağ
[Müzik]
Lama
alışır Her insan
alışır
zamanla kır
ılır incin
ki
[Müzik]
olur yık
IP yeniden
yalnız
ım yollarım
a su kurmuş
beklemekte
acıları Gözlerini
dikmiş üstüme nöbette
[Müzik]
diyorum
hadi
gitmiyorum
yol
larıma hoş Bekle bekle
acılar Gözlerini dikmiş üstüme
nöbette bekliyorum bekliyorum
[Müzik]
bekliyorum
üstümüze Hasret
yok
luğun başını
Nihayet
[Müzik]
[Alkış]
bul
utlar Tüm özel Has
ret
yokluğun baş baş
ayım
Nihal Yıldız
lı
yollarıma pusu kurmuş Bekle bekle
acıları Gözlerini dikmiş üstüme
nöbette bekliyorum bekliyorum
bekliyorum bekliyorum
[Müzik]
kokusu kurmuş bek
le acıları Gözlerini dikmiş üstüme
nöbette
[Müzik]
Melek
üst
üme kork
[Müzik]
[Alkış]
muyorum
[Müzik]
bir aleme indim yalnız
yerde Toprak Gökte Yıldız
yan susuz bir yan beni
Belli ki el bir baş verdiler
[Müzik]
Bir çift göz ağlar da
Gülen dört
bir yay
ile
[Müzik]
söz için mi içtin
kalbin Sev dediler
bana
ya söylediler Bana Yalan Söylediler
kaderden bahsetmediler
[Müzik]
Bana Yalan
Söylediler bana yalan
söyle derdinden bahsetmediler
varsın böyle
Sinem
bari her günüm
hani benim
sevdiklerim hani gönül
verdiklerim hasret gider
Ben giderim
hani benim
sevdikleri hani gönül verdiklerim
[Müzik]
[Alkış]
varsın
böyle Sinem
[Müzik]
neşeyle dolsun bari her gün
üm
sevdim hani gönül verdiklerim hasret
gider
Ben giderim
[Müzik]
hani benim
sevdiklerim hani gönül verdiklerim
Hasret
[Müzik]
gibi
[Alkış]
gider
im gider
[Müzik]
[Alkış]
im sevgili Zafer Çebi Hocama Üstadı
kocaman bir alkış rica ediyorum
[Alkış]